so brendan you sent this to me yesterday
and i watched this clip it's
marc maron on is it a clip because this
is my because i didn't i didn't look
into it i didn't see it i saw this i'm
like this would be good for the show
yeah but when i saw him like i need to
know the context
there was a clip this was uh mark maron
on tom segura's show do we have the clip
uh there's a clip on youtube somewhere
it's not on this particular
chin because before we talk about man
who i actually like
and i think he's a great comic before we
talked about maren he's been on this
show and
he's one of my favorite podcasters he
you know him and rogan started the same
year
but i need to see the clip i i saw that
he said it wasn't you know i think that
you know you're your own guy you're your
own life
you weren't one of the guys that you
know rented out space and joe's ass
yeah it's just like there's like a human
centipede in austin it's like
elon musk joe rogan and three middle
acts
so he's being funny but you seem to do
your own thing yeah
well yeah i mean we have our own you
know our own see people are going to see
that and go like look at mary he's
bitter it's like
why wouldn't i be white oh he's a
millionaire million dollars for going
i don't know this is this rival price
really
that's right that's right hey brogan's
pushing back
i don't know man so
that's fair he's being funny but like
yeah i'm not going to
sit here and it's definitely best and as
the next shangri-la
yeah because people always forget to
finish the sentence you know
hey man i'm moving to austin texas
yes yeah yeah it's still texas oh it's
really texas it's really texas it's like
the hipster alamo it's this little
enclave it does feel like you're in
you're totally in a different unit like
obviously it's the most time i've ever
spent there usually you come in you do
a weekend of shows right you know but
it's it is not
like any other texas experience you know
no
it is though i always liked it i mean
you know i i
i think what he said was funny and he's
being silly in in a
joe's joe's fine joe will be fine
my only problem is when he goes you know
them giving 100 million to rogan for his
pushback's going oh really man like
that's the only way i don't agree with
mayor
well um like that's not why rogan got
hundred million
like you can't say rogan's not a yeah
but he's joking i mean obviously we know
that
again that's shade for sure okay it's a
little shade but it's fine
but also i thought it was funny but it's
the same the parts were
really funny yeah um but they're and i
do like men
but there is uh you know rogan's the
cool kid in town everybody knows you got
100 million dollars so it's like with
drake like
if you're an upcoming rap and not that
mark man's up and coming but if you're
like a rapper that's big in the field
like if you're gonna take shots you're
gonna take shots at drake because a he's
not going to respond he's
he's killing it you know and b like he's
yeah he's the head honcho yeah so that's
the guy you shoot
that that's fine that's not gonna that's
all good we're just [ __ ] around
everybody's friends
it's well they're not friends but yeah
yeah but they're fine with each other i
mean
mark and joe have known each other for
26 years 27 not friends
no okay but they're not enemies you know
they're not they don't [ __ ] with each
other
i've known those guys together for a
long time and i've had conversations
about them with each other and there's
not there's not animosity it just isn't
there's just they're just different
people
they're very different people with very
different audiences yeah i agree
there's one one's jazz one's [ __ ]
hundred percent hard rock
different and both
again they're two completely different i
think what mark said was actually funny
and he was being silly and it's just a
podcast and he's saying [ __ ]
but i get i get with mary like
everyone's saying austin's like the end
all be all like
guys it's like yeah you shut the [ __ ] up
i agree with that yeah i'm with him yeah
i'm with him i mean i was like
but the only the only part where i don't
ride with mark was like dude 100 million
from being like uh
i guess i don't know like come on yeah
that's that's okay yeah
i mean that's the issue again though
again i don't take that seriously i
don't think mark takes that seriously i
think we're just being
i think that joe joe joe probably
had part of joe's what is it um
what would you say his part of his um
technique and personality is not to push
back
is to let people talk he's pushed back
and say say their thing just push back a
ton
if you don't agree with it you're gonna
push back for sure yeah he'll push back
but for the most part he's also
well he likes to take himself out of it
and listen to what the person says
once you get your point across so he's
he has a lot of times where if he
doesn't agree with you
or if he has if he thinks something else
he definitely
there's also a lot but there's a lot of
times when he's had people on who he
doesn't agree with i know for a fact
i've seen it where he doesn't agree at
all but he'll let them he'll let them
speak
yeah and then he'll just he'll get their
point and then
part of that is a is what he would
consider good podcasting because
he's he's taking them asking them how
they think
and then listening to them if he starts
pushing back right away they're going to
clam up
they're going to shut down right and
their points aren't getting so if you
have a three-hour conversation and
you're going to start shutting people
down what happens is that podcast
becomes one hour correct so so to
so i understand why he doesn't push back
in some cases because he wants
to hear what they have to say and i know
for a fact there are people where he
just is like that guy doesn't know what
the [ __ ] he's talking about for sure but
he's not gonna shut you down because
that's kind of not his or hers
if he thinks you're out of out of line
yeah i've seen joe is not afraid i've
seen
that when people are lying or when
they're being dismissed yes
yeah 100 yeah but if somebody's a
socialist he's also made a hundred
million dollars to do what he does
it's not my it's not what i it's his
thing but that's his thing it's in a
three-hour conversation and what happens
is you
so when he had bernie sanders on who
i've always disagreed with
but when you hear him joe doesn't joe
voted for joe
does and doesn't and some some things
don't vote agrees and other stuff
yeah but for some something it was a
huge advocate for bernie sanders
and bernie going on joe's show helped
out bernie sanders tremendously
when i heard bernie on joe so what
happened was i was like
he didn't sounds extreme right he
sounded a little bit more
reasonable and so what happens when you
listen to that is that that's what i
like about joe's podcast
is you hear somebody not in five minutes
but in three hours
be able to tell or even an hour or
whatever it was with burning and that's
a long time
i've never heard him get a chance to do
that on tv so you hear him
be able to work through ideas that's the
value 100
100 that's what's great about podcasting
you get the whole
complete person i mean uh marinade
[ __ ] all